welcome to this video playing black
against the tomato fine again yeah get
many games going against the sky ok
trying something trying something
different oops not that one ok so got a
sort of b6 maybe I just take just take
it down see if I can get some decent
development going um yeah so just 97 I
guess hmm Quincy for says some there is
no trick or anything I just is not
taking right away but thinking about if
there's some trickery with Bishop every
night if I ever have those kind of
things if he takes but there's always
this annoying check on b5 so that's not
going to work I just want to have a
smooth development with e-cigs maybe c5
this should be fairly a fairly solid
position nothing great but definitely
definitely playable yeah this loosely
looks a lot like the Catalan opening
yeah one day we should play a quick see
5 or not maybe maybe
rook c8 yeah this there are positions
like that where black has played a 6b
five instead of b6 which is a difference
a 6b five gains more space but also
weakens weakens a bit okay so i can take
here in one move nothing yeah I mean I
appreciate the possibility that this is
this is a happening of oneness yeah he
has to move the Queen again I think
probably 2 D 3 or 10 h from yeah okay I
guess I'll just I just castle how to how
to do without it in the long run anyway
so yeah this is a typical problem my
queen does not have a really great spot
with the look on the one yeah I wonder
just maybe Queenie 70 is this impasse or
if I go 95 maybe 95
95 immediately 95 I have aged six I
don't know i should i should play
something not use more time and i'm not
sure i'm not sure that this is great the
whole situation looks a bit not it's not
a very hem Onias position takes Queen
age form I take on edge form Knight
takes he gets this M get the pawn on d5
Bishop g5 comes into consideration now
yeah or this one yeah I actually thought
that that age six should be should be ok
but maybe it's not well just Knight f6
is got default some okay that's not
looking good now if you does he have
luke t five maybe luke t five I guess
not if you just need to retreat the
position is not such a big issue for me
the isolated Queen porn yeah he tries to
do that okay um so I take and what's the
point now I'm taking with the bishop so
I go here
hmm much sure that they understand the
whole thing is there I don't see how
what what the problem is at the moment
taking you to and they have 95 g6
possibly not really see see the issue
hmm yeah just a piece of am I not I mean
okay it's two points but no we are two
pawns okay bishop is seven yeah this
move but that's really working I have
home Queenie six at least intermediate
attack or or something else not really
Queenie six is kabuki one it's not
helping I didn't really see before
missed em and you could move here you
don't see it don't see anything great I
kept trying fall for this counter play
95 to g6 I need to get the night away
from this have analysis a pretty bad bad
place here to e5 or then is playing
plane Queenie for probably hmm
I have Queenie no I have clearly six and
that's a little of nice little trick
takes takes a check okay Queen f3 maybe
then I can take only two when all of a
sudden I'm I'm junk back in the game
well the bishop hangs so it's equal
material and I have fun he has this open
King position I can take I have Queen f5
Jack to do seven white resign yes was a
very very bad position probably yeah the
position out of the opening here is is a
bit it's questionable I mean 95 I guess
should be the problem i don't i don't
think that that here i have anything big
to hear it looks our face got all pieces
out so maybe Queenie seven I didn't I
didn't really want to put it here
because this Bishop is not really having
a natural square maybe d6 but it looks
vulnerable on the default I wasn't
really sure about it yeah I guess my
move is not that great not sure mother
compute X s equal takes takes and now
Bishop g5 and Bishop e2 ok and here yeah
age 60 is good it's good for black still
I wondered after this why not just
Knight f3 Knight f3
okay yeah that's in fact interesting the
compounds to go Knight f6 immediately I
was I was thinking about I was more
thinking about this trying to misplace a
snide but it's not that misplaced of
course okay with Knight f6 also possible
that is that is really okay I mean the
computer gives me a huge advantage which
I don't really believe but and it's
clear that i have no problem i have all
my pieces are fine and the point is not
not really weak and i was really
surprised that this should work but the
main problem is and missed f6 yeah i
should play a six i know i didn't miss
that i was just thinking okay on this
end after before him I can still play f6
I really didn't say I think about the
move yeah maybe I'm too averse to play
this ugly moves but they are of course
it's a technically good move it keeps
the peace okay I didn't see that that
went for this and now Bishop e7 could be
good yeah more possible yeah idea this
is of course funny funny true career
with Queenie six now rooty for is best
and after this i 95 was even possible so
even stronger not sure why I naija form
that is even stronger okay I was content
with getting getting this back and
having an advantage I'm furthering this
and threatening the bishop that this is
tricky Queen d2 is the only move that
it's not losing immediately and here he
is losing yeah Utley yeah bit of a
strange quick win um I think that
probably probably hear Y should should
be content with something like like
Bishop g5 okay thanks for watching